so to do this we need to
Convert from Polar to coordinate system.
if you remember how we started our session today, we we said
that
we put a point on the Cartesian space.
And in math, we just draw a line, but in Python, we
have to create a sequence of points leading up to that point.
so for example five steps are along the x-axis
and then five steps along the y-axis and
that's where we put the point and then we draw a line leading to that point.
But if you notice here when we do draw this Vector we have now formed
an angle.
We have formed an angle from the x-axis to
the
to the line
There's a word for this I think there's initial side and
the terminal side. So this is the initial side.
Relative to the x-axis is the initial side. That's the terminal side
relative to the y-axis. That would be the initial side. And
this would be the terminal side. And
anyway, so on the Cartesian coordinate
system, we have the values X and Y and that produces the
point.
in the polar coordinate system we have
R which is the radius
And the coordinate the polar coordinates is
a circle. We'll see this in a second and the angle of theta.
So if you know these values if you know the the length of the
vector.
and it's
Angle from the initial side, then you will know its position
on the polar coordinate system, but there's a way we can convert we can
go from one system to another system.
Let me show you the polar coordinate system on its own polar coordinate
system.
Okay.
These are the coordinates.
on the
Holocaust system, obviously
the point one point would be the length of the vector that
will always be the case and then
there is radian. And what's the other one? Yeah in
Radiance how how far it
is from the initial side.
Okay.
And this is the radian system.
You get the idea hope?
okay, so if you want to for example go from
Polar to
Cartesian you calculated this way.
We go X will be equal to R.
Which is the radius?
times
Yeah sign of the angle Theta.
and if you want the Y you multiply by
the cosine
Theta
This is how you convert.
We know have the angle Theta for our cosine similarity
now. We just need to multiply it. But
well we need to
Calculate the sign of that.
Angle which will give us the ratio.
for sine, it will be the ratio will be
opposite over hypotenuse, right?
And cosine would be yeah, I just over hypotenuse.
So if I want the X and Y from my cosine similarity, I'm
going to come back to my notebook.
I will call this.
Cos or see Sim one
cosine similarity for the first comparison.
Cosine sub let's make it one and two right the
cosine similarity of vectors 1 and 2 the cosine
similarity of vectors.
Two and three or let's make this one and three.
to convert
to Cartesian
now
we cannot plot these wood vectors because we have
to project this in the two-dimensional space. These are four dimensional. So
what we're going to do is we're going to
create two vectors that go from all from 0
to 5. Basically, let me show you what I mean. Okay, so
I'm going to create those three vectors again that this be
Five five okay five steps from the x-axis five
steps to the y-axis.
Let me go back to what I had before.
I need to be more careful.
Okay, so that's the let me let me let me make the vector a
bit longer. So we'll go from 10 to 10.
Now after we have calculated the cosine similarity.
We need to grab the X and Y for the second.
vector
so
The formula was as follows if I want
to draw the second vector.
I'm going to go V.
W2
Okay.
the position of this Vector is relative to Vector 1
so for its X
Or it's X I'm going to call the vector function to draw a vector.
And this will have to be a tuple.
So for we have X and Y, correct.
So it's going to be math.
What the sine? Of course? I think it was sine math DOT
sign of C.
cosine similarity I wanted to
Same thing for why it's gonna copy this bit.
But this would be cosine.
Okay. Now I'm going to draw the second vector.
We'll make this red.
Okay.
Well, is this good or bad or is this close or
not? So not close. There's only one way to know that's to create a third vector.
So I'm going to create a third vector.
This will be the course now the angle for these functions would
be the cosine similarity of 1 and 3.
So we first compare one and two now we compare one and three.
And let me make the first Vector black.
That's the that's our.
point of reference
And then we will make the green one.
Let me let me draw this again.
Just so you can see the black vector.
So that's the original one.
and then
let's add the third vector.
third Factor
now one more time because I forgot to change reassign this
value. So again, this is the first vector.
This was a dog right supposedly dog. This is
cat.
And now let's do the building.
And let's make the color.
green
Yeah.
So you can see.
dog and cat
or closer to each other to have a
smaller angle